[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 19th of
may i'm john connelly the spectator's
news editor and your host this week
on this week's show
james forsyth writes in this week's
cover piece about zolensky's choice
should the ukrainian president fight on
or accept the loss of ukrainian land as
the price of peace he'll discuss with
professor sergey radchenko
we've now got talk tv gb news and of
course spectator tv what's behind the
explosion of political and news shows
we'll speak to veteran broadcasters
andrew neal and ian dale
katie bulls writes in her column this
week that boris johnson is looking for a
scrap but can the prime minister decide
who he wants to fight cater joins me to
discuss the government's latest
political strategy
and speaking of upcoming rouse the uk's
battle with the european union over the
northern ireland protocol is heating up
too i'll speak with ivan rogers about
the potential looming trade war
and finally why is the bbc trying to
bury a radical series it made in the
1960s peter hitchens will join us on the
show to talk about the programme that
may well be too dangerous to broadcast
before we get going a very special thank
you to canaccord genuity wealth
management who is sponsoring the week in
60 minutes canaccord are experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who go above and beyond to offer you
support and guidance just visit
candywealth.com to find out more
and why not subscribe to our youtube
channel click the red subscribe button
at the bottom of the video and tap the
bell icon to make sure you never miss an
episode
first up what's the end game in ukraine
in this week's cover piece james forsyth
writes that pleasant zelinski has a
choice should he keep fighting russia
and hope to push them completely out of
the donbass or should he look to
negotiate with putin and accept they'll
have to succeed some territory to russia
to discuss james joins me now along with
sergey radchenko professor of the
kissinger center at johns hopkins
university
sergey james thank you for joining us
now james you're writing your piece this
week that the sort of beginning to see
fractures in the west when it comes to
ukraine for example we've sort of seen
volkswagen say now that it we need to
return to normal relations we've seen
macron call putin frequently what are
the sort of dividing lines of the west
now that we're going to be heading
towards hopefully negotiations and where
are these cracks going to open up do you
think
so i think the unity that has been on
display from the west since the invasion
has been far greater than anyone
expected i mean there are two reasons
for that one putin went for the most
maximalist
invasion option possible and secondly
the kind of bravery of the the ukrainian
people has i think kind of struck a
chord in the west both of its leaders
and its publics but i think there is now
a question because the military balance
is turning and i think in the next few
weeks there is a possibility he could
turn more you know you look at the fact
that the us is sending 40 billion uh
dollars worth of aid to ukraine the
purely military part of that is greater
than uh the defense budget of canada
and so the question then becomes what
should ukraine's war aims be should it
merely be to uh push the russians back
from where they are now to where they
were before the invasion in february or
should it be to try and recapture all
the territory that ukraine has lost
since 2014 i think there are divides in
the west on that front uh and then the
question of you know if you could get to
a situation where russia came to a
negotiating table in a serious manner
and i think that won't happen until
russia loses this kind of land corridor
from the crimea to donbass that it is in
the process of acquiring uh should the
sanctions all go or should only some of
the sanctions go and should there be
some kind of snapback mechanism in place
to prevent russian revolutionism and so
i think these are the questions and i
think the biggest question is how to
handle russia
you look at macron saying that putin
shouldn't be humiliated you look at what
the estonians are saying
echo by other countries in in the baltic
and eastern europe and they're saying
that you know russia mustn't just lose
but must be seen to lose
and sergey on that point saying macron
there saying last week that russia can't
be humiliated you can sort of see his
argument there you sort of need to give
russia an off-ramp a way out or bridge
out of the conflict do you kind of agree
with his assessment or or not
well to some extent but not certainly
not fully here's here's what the situat
you know the situation is this we had a
very interesting by the way interesting
claim
or interesting discussion of this uh uh
earlier by a timothy snyder
who said
that uh you know putin creates his own
reality he doesn't need offrams because
he simply can say that he won and
because he controls media space and
russia then everybody will say oh yeah
yeah we want a great victory so
therefore we can go home
therefore the west doesn't need to do
anything simply it needs to create more
pressure to change the reality on the
ground um i think in general this is the
right approach however i would also
caution here in saying that i don't
think that putin entirely entirely uh
creates his own reality and i think it
is still important to maintain back
channel communication i mean russia
remains in nuclear power we're still
worried about escalation
of this war therefore having back
channel communication and having back
channel diplomacy is essential now we
don't know how much of this is happening
uh out of the public eye we just don't
know at this stage we we know that the
russians and the ukrainians are not
talking to each other much uh we do not
know to what extent let's say
washington is speaking to moscow at this
stage well there's some some
conversations that are taking place
but uh you know this this conflict will
have to have a negotiated solution at
some point so presumably we'll have to
move towards the diplomatic track the
question is when
and james it's an interesting point
where do you sort of draw that line i
mean i know g7 leaders said last week
that russia shouldn't be rewarded at all
for its invasion of ukraine do you think
that means russia has to be pushed out
of ukrainian territory entirely before
we can sort of accept them coming to the
negotiating table
i i think the way to think about it is
this is if russia is pushed back to
where it was before february the 24th i
mean you can say that it has had no
rewards for this invasion i think crimea
is a very difficult question because uh
russia now claims that it is part of its
own territory and i think if you ended
up with ukraine pushing into crimea
which is a long way off militarily but
if you end up in a situation where
ukraine is pushing into crimea using
western weaponry
which it would be you know there is
obviously an escalatory risk there when
you talk to people on the british side
one thing they point out is that the
north crimea canal which controls the
water supply to crimea the russians have
captured that during this war if the
ukrainians could recapture it you know
that provides the basis for a
negotiation i i also think it's quite
clear that zielenski himself is prepared
to negotiate over crimea and as one
figure in the british government put it
to me you know you can't be more
ukrainian than the ukrainians so if
zolensky himself is prepared to
negotiate on crimea i i and i think
given the escalatory risks of uh
the ukrainians going into something that
russia considers to be russian territory
then i think that you know the the
crimea is one of those questions best
left for the peace talks i mean the
west's overall aim should be to send the
ukrainians into a negotiating chamber in
the strongest possible position i mean
you mentioned earlier sergey about
escalation russia is obviously a nuclear
state it has many hundreds of nuclear
missiles there's clearly going to be a
red line at some point where do you
think that red line would be when maybe
russia would actually start to think
about you know escalating the conflict
in that regard are we miles away from
that still
nobody knows with nuclear weapons it's
it's very interesting because you know
they've been around for decades but of
course outside of hiroshima and nagasaki
they have not actually been used so we
do not know exactly how deterrence works
we think we know we assume we know but
uh we're not sure we're not sure whether
being tougher on putin for example
contributes to a risk of escalation or
by contrast decreases the risk of
escalation it's not it's not so clear
one may make some assumption for example
if putin sees that his
survival is in danger presumably he
would be more likely to use nuclear
weapons to assure his survival but
whether
he will see
victories in ukraine tied up with his
domestic survival is another question
altogether and those people who are
today saying we should be tougher with
the russians in ukraine say that
actually putin can afford to lose all of
ukraine or at least all of that
territory that he had gained since
february 24th
um
and and still survived just fine
and james what's what's america's
position here because obviously they've
gone balancing quite a few sort of
viewpoints now across europe how do they
think that russia should be brought to
the you know negotiating table
i i think the american view is and you
look at the amount of aid that the the
us is now pumping into to ukraine is i
think they would like to see the
russians push back to where they were
before this conflict started and then i
think they also
would take the view that in the longer
term the west should be careful about
resuming the kind of previous economic
relationships that it had with russia
you know if as the u.s defense secretary
has said you want to be in a situation
where russia can't do this kind of thing
again that raises the question of
whether you really do want to return to
uh uh exporting kind of key bits of
technology to russia that allow advanced
manufacturing particularly of of of
things that can be used for defense or
military purposes so i think we are i
think that the question of what happens
to the sanctions on russia at the end of
this conflict
i think that that is another issue where
there will be there will be a continuum
of opinion among western countries you
know should it be the aim to kind of
return to some kind of status quo anti
or should it be an aim to uh to leave
russia in a position that leaves it
permanently weakened
and james do you think removing
sanctions should be on the table at all
at least to encourage russia to the
negotiating table
uh i think at the beginning of this that
for example
sanctions such as on the russian central
bank
those would probably have to be lifted
at an early stage in negotiations i
think some of the other sanctions
are more complex i think one thing that
you've seen the g7 discussing is whether
you should have some kind of snap back
mechanism so essentially the sanctions
are lifted but they can be uh reimposed
at speed and that that would act as a
kind of deterrence to uh further uh
russian revolutism or
uh the russians attempting to restart
any uh conflict in ukraine
and sergey it's also the case that you
know if a deal is reached there's
obviously must be a risk that russia
will go away for a few years it will
rearm and then it will become once again
become a massive threat again on the
world stage and how do we go about
preventing that or is there sort of
nothing we can do about that at this
stage
i think we we are
missing the the big game here where we
do not have a long-term strategy with
regard to russia we're talking about
putin as if putin is a permanent fixture
on the russian stage we do not know of
course how how long he'll last maybe
he'll last for a month maybe four years
maybe you know over a decade so it is
indeed indeed difficult to a do
something with putin or even plan for a
post-putin world however i think it is
important to start thinking in that
direction and what just james just said
just now is actually very interesting
uh
part of that broader conversation
sanctions relief you know how do you
lift sanctioned sanctions especially in
the united states you know the united
states is famous for imposing sanctions
and not and then forgetting to lift them
for decades extremely difficult to do
that in the in in the american context
uh but suppose putin drops debt today
suppose he drops dead and suppose we
have some kind of a new constellation of
leaders it's not
let's say it's not going to be navalny
but maybe somebody from putin's
immediate circle um what is the west's
position in this case you know will the
west maintain kind of very hard position
on russia or will the west offer some
incentives for change and i would i
would imagine that some form of
incentives and kind of long-term
conversation about where russia belongs
in the european order etc is of essence
we cannot at the moment we do not know
how to imagine russia's future we kind
of think that russia will just go away
and we are keen to keep it that way
to weaken it perhaps i don't know
sometimes you know we hear this
statement about weakening russia
what does that mean does it mean
breaking up russia into small pieces or
feuding peace you know feuding provinces
that turning on on one another i will
personally think that's actually very
dangerous scenario given that russia is
a nuclear power uh and and and so we
need to have imaginative thinking about
russia doesn't mean that at the moment i
know what that that would look like but
somehow we need to figure out how to
anchor russia to the european and world
war
and sergey um one final point before we
finish up do you think russia has any
incentive to negotiate at this stage or
do you think we're going to have to see
more fighting to see it push back
further before it will eventually come
to the table
at the moment it doesn't seem like the
russians have been beaten back enough i
mean the ukrainians have been doing a
fantastic job of course and and putin
has failed to achieve his primary
objectives or indeed his secondary
objectives uh he's still working at it
we see that the war continues and don
bass
in the coming weeks we'll see how this
war goes if it starts fizzling out uh if
it becomes clear that the ukrainians are
in position to push back and to hold the
lines as well against the russians then
i think putin will start coming around
to
the recognition of importance of
negotiating uh some sort of a
a peaceful exit from from from this
terrible situation until then i think
the right position for the western to
simply continue supporting ukraine brian
thank you sergey and thank you james
seems that wherever you are in britain
at the moment it's impossible to escape
piers morgan's face in fact the entire
country seems to be overrun with adverts
for new tv channels or shows whether
that's gb news talk tv or andrew lbc
so what's exactly going on here and
what's behind this huge growth in news
broadcasting i'm joined now by andre
neal chairman of the spectator and host
of the andrew neil show on channel 4 and
ian dale the host of lbc's evening show
to discuss
andrew ian thank you for joining us now
andrew to start us off i think in the
past bbc executives have said that when
it comes to broadcasting news is less
competitive than other forms if you look
at the number of shows that are
launching at the moment that definitely
doesn't seem to be the case what do
things changed here
well i think the bbc executives were
wrong they were wrong when they said it
and they're even more wrong now uh
my old mate who i'm a huge fan of tony
hall the former director general of the
bbc he said well there's a market in
entertainment but there's not a market
in news and current affairs
and that was it was just simply wrong
because of the proliferation of
platforms uh both traditional and
non-traditional there's quite a vibrant
market in britain in news and current
affairs and the bbc has found that out
the hard way but the number of famous
names that have left the bbc to go to
other news and current affairs providers
uh
now and and there is as there has been
in america for a long time as there is
in france and germany too now there is
quite a market in using current affairs
the bbc doesn't pay that much these days
so it's it's been easy for commercial
broadcasters to lure
bbc presenters from this meetless to mr
soppo eddie mayer started the process
andrew marr has gone there too
there is a clear dynamic and quite
robust market in news and current
affairs now and uh i think that's
healthy
i think it's good that that's the case
and that the bbc
is not the only place not that a serious
country first presenter can go to the
what has changed
is the proliferation of platforms the
ability to
do things in various digital uh ways
i mean ian i think of all the names
andrew mentioned there of bbc stars
who've been poached i think all of them
have gone to lbc i mean why do you think
it is that lbc has been able to take on
all that talent and uh and what kind of
market are they aiming for there
well it's partly because global radio
have really invested in news and current
affairs over the last 10 years if you
think about lbc back in the days when
andrew was presenting on it when i first
started in 2010 it was a london-based
station we went national in 2014 and
global have invested millions of pounds
not just in so-called talent but also in
the studios we've now got a studio at
four mil bank in westminster which i
present from three days a week
i don't know how much that cost but it
was it will have been quite a lot and it
is better than any other studio in that
building and i think the bbc's problem
is i mean their problems are as under
articulated but also they haven't really
invested in using current affairs for a
very very long time their studios look
tired they're still using the same theme
music as they used 20 years ago and it's
not a gripping watch there's very little
innovation going on whereas i think you
see that not just the lbc but other
places too
andrew i mean you appeared in front of
the lord's committee this week and said
that the bbc needs kind of a radical
shake up do you think there's been a
sort of a complacency there and now
they're being caught out
there is a certain complacency but that
complacency is born of finances i mean
since 2010 the bbc has had a
a cut a cumulative cut in real terms
real terms of 30 of his income
and
yet it's still on its imperial mission
to do everything with all these radio
stations all these tv channels massive
online and all the rest of it
and it just doesn't in this environment
it doesn't have the resources to do
everything and and ian is quite right
uh about this bbc news whose journalism
is still superb and you know we see
stuff coming in from ukraine the
journalists there have just been
world-class
but they don't have the modern backup in
terms of technology graphics package the
look of the studio and all the rest of
it um
that is for fit for the 2020s i mean
i've said several times i sit in my
apartment in new york
and i go through the news belt of all
the news channel
stations that are available there and
the bbc's on it as well and when you
come to the bbc in terms of the look the
feel the lack of energy about it the
graphics it's like a walk back into the
1970s
and in a a competitive environment that
won't do i mean the lbc studio looks
great the talk tv studio great looks
great i wanted the gb news studio to
look great as well as everyone can see i
failed in that
but you do have if you just look at
american
or even french
news channels now bfm tv or c5 then on a
different look from the a different uh
platform from the bbc and how to do that
so it is a function of money that the
bbc is trying to stretch out uh
resources that are declining in real
terms beyond what they can really
provide which is why i suggested that
perhaps although continuing with the
license fee
would be the most comfortable and
easiest thing to do
it is probably a way to ensure the
continued decline of the bbc
and in turning to those competitors now
we've obviously got talk tv gb news both
launching new channels um how do you see
these channels as working out in the
long term do you think they're going to
going to be a success or do you think
they're going to struggle
i think it's too early to judge that if
you look at the audience figures
certainly for talk tv in its first month
i mean bear in mind we are only i think
three or four weeks into it and that
they are pretty disappointing i can't
imagine anyone at news uk thinking that
this has been an outrageous success um
andrew's right it looks quite good that
they have certainly learned from the
mistakes at gb news initially as to the
the look and pierce morgan's studio i
don't know how much is green screen or
how much is actually physical but it
looks good and that is par i mean you
have to have the visuals right if you're
going to succeed as a television channel
but i think the big question is
is there extra audience or all these new
entrants to the market going to chip
away at existing these audiences well
last night i i got my
radar listening figures and i mean i was
a bit to be honest i was a bit
apprehensive because of all these new
entries to the market but actually we've
gone up fifty thousand um it's a it's a
record audience share for my evening
show which is now up against piers
morgan tom newton done
talk radio times radio all of these new
entrants that weren't there 18 months
ago so um they haven't chipped away at
my audience very much so far thank
goodness um but i i'm not sure
that they can make it commercially
viable with the audience levels that
they've got and i suspect that there
will be a bit of battle between talk tv
and gb news which will be great for all
of us to observe but i suspect it's a
bit like uh b sky b or sky and bsb there
will only be one winner
andrew what's your thoughts on why talk
tv is kind of underwhelming so far as
you say it's got the top production
values but not the not the viewing
figures well i think there's a number of
reasons uh
it's likely that the very model itself
is not fit for purpose in the sense that
doing
three hours of what you might call
proper television between seven o'clock
and 10 o'clock every night
but for the other 24 hours per day of
the clock you basically do radio with
pictures
that maybe probably isn't the way
forward
but if i was rupert murdoch and clearly
i'm not
i would call nigel farage their old
mates and i would say nige come to a
proper studio with proper sound and
proper lighting and proper production
values come on at seven o'clock just do
what you do
and i want a really lively hand over to
piers morgan at eight o'clock
and andrew on that point i mean i know
you were very critical of gb news when
you left do you feel like it sort of
found its feet a bit more now i know
it's sort of competing a bit more doing
better viewing figures than sky news for
example
yes no i have i don't see the full
figures i take all the i take most news
reports of the figures with a pinch of
salt because they're usually presented
by someone who's an axe to grind in
favor of one particular channel there is
no question that uh gb news has got
better i mean there was only one way to
go but there is no question that has got
better i i mean
farage is the anchor
which is why in old frite street
parliaments it would be a double whammy
to get for ash because you would hit gb
news and you would bring him on then his
80
000 viewers or whatever it is he gets
now to talk tv i mean imagine if piers
inherited 80 000
viewers at eight o'clock at night then
what would he build that up between
eight and nine
but gb news i think has shown
in a way that top tv hasn't
that if you're going to do television
news you need to do it as television
news
and that's what gb news is well for all
its faults and its weaknesses and its
technology and its look and it's still
the worst looking of all the news
channels
though it is better no question about
that it is a news channel
and i think if you if you want to do
news on tv
you have to do news on tv and not just
make a radio with pictures on tv so
that's at that extent the gb news model
i think is a better model than the top
tv model
do you agree with that ian do you think
some gb news can do well and sort of
found its niche there
well i agree with andrew that it is a
better model than talk tv because i mean
whoever thought having sharon osborne on
at nine o'clock was a good idea
following piers morgan i mean i know
they're friends and maybe he insisted on
it as part of the deal i don't know but
that was a major major error and i think
i think that the experience of the last
few months has shown that you can do
radio on tv but you can't do tv on radio
if you listen to gb news radio for
example in your car it is virtually
unlistenable
and obviously over the past two or three
years
radio most radio stations now visualize
what they do
we don't stream everything we do but we
put out a huge amount of clips the
intention is that they go
viral and many of them do
um but it doesn't really work the other
way and i'm not sure
that i see
anybody taking a very positive lesson
from what gb news have done on the radio
and do you think it's sort of odd that
tv channels are sort of going into their
four now when everything's moving online
do you think they sort of missed the
boat slightly or i've got that wrong
well talk tv will try and convince you
that they're not worried about their low
audience figures on on sort of uh linear
digital tv they say yes but we're
getting audiences on all sorts of
different platforms now they're right to
some extent but i wonder how large those
audiences are for example piers morgan
on youtube is not getting many views
at all given he is who he is um sections
of my show getting far more viewers on
youtube and we don't even promote the
fact that we're actually on youtube so
um
i i think we we do live in a
multi-platform atmosphere at the moment
and you you can't just rely on i mean a
radio station now is not just on fm it
has to be on digital radio it has to
have a web present it has to have a
twitter presence and if you
i mean most radio stations now add all
of the views together as if they're
listeners so as andrew said with some of
the the overnight figures that you get
for the tv programs radio listenerships
are often a work of fiction too apart
from ours obviously
i mean i think that you know whatever
happens the market will sort that out
the viewers will sort it out i do think
we live in a great age if you're a
viewer or a listener
i mean there was a time in britain uh
that there was huge competition between
bbc news and itv which was done by itn
itn provided the news for itv and indeed
there was a time when music 10 on itv
was a far superior product to bbc news
at nine o'clock
and there was real competition and
people moved between the bbc and itv and
so on because my great mentor alistair
burnett uh was the anchor for the launch
of news at 10 which at one stage was
getting 12 million viewers uh of an
evening how about that for a new show
then for reasons i never quite
understood michael grade and others and
itv decided they were basically going to
sideline news
and itn was downgraded and itv news
became a lot less important and greg
dyke at the bbc very cleverly moved the
nine o'clock news to the ten o'clock
news at the time and it dominated all
the news then itv had moved to 10 30
which was too late and the bbc became
the dominant provider of television news
and radio news in the way it hadn't been
for television when itn had been the big
beast with itv news and that has been
going on for too long
and we've ended that here and now we're
ending an era of bbc dominance in news
bbc will still be very important
probably still by far the most important
provider but there are lots of new kids
on the block lbc is now a major national
player in the provision of news and
current affairs
to do it talk tv is on gb news is there
channel 4
news is still there doing an hour of
news every night and
some of you may have noticed we started
a new show on channel four at six
o'clock on on a sunday at night itv
has rediscovered news and as i say doing
90 minutes of news every evening with
local news rolled in from six o'clock at
night and there's all sorts of other
things that i'm sure i've missed out
that are online as well and channel 5
does a good news service again made by
itn now will all of these survive over
time probably not because the market
probably isn't big enough to handle them
all but the competition will be good the
choice is fantastic
and people watching i missed out of
course spectator tv which is a wonderful
new addition to the british broadcasting
firmaments i mean what more could you
want and so if you're a viewer or a
listener it's a great time you got more
choice than ever before so enjoy it and
let other people worry about who will
succeed or who will make or lose money
in the long run if you're a viewer or a
listener you don't have to worry about
that
and on that positive note let's end
there thank you andrew and thank you ian
katie balls writes in this week's
politics column that boris johnson is
looking to pick a fight to divide the
opposition but does the pm have a proper
plan and are there not more important
problems facing the country casey joins
me now to discuss
thank you katie for joining us um katie
you're right in the magazine this week
that boris johnson can't decide whether
he wants to be a great unifier or a
great divider can you tell us a bit
about what that means
yes i mean i think we're back to a
problem we've often seen with boris
johnson's government where there are
lots of people around him giving him
advice and they tend to fall into
different camps and no one is quite sure
where the prime minister sits um so if
you think about boris johnson in the
2019 election and brexit i think was
often someone who would use you know
fights or uh picking uh one side such as
for example uh proroguing parliament to
make a point to a specific group whereas
in the city hall days he would he
describes himself as this great unifier
who um you know it was almost a form of
cuddly conservatism i think these days
you can see from various policy plans
the government is very much leaning
towards fight mode uh you have a
situation where um
the plan to send
asylum seekers to rwanda uh you also
have jacob rees-mogg's crackdown on
civil servants and working from home and
which you seem to do you know random
spot checks of departments um and done
in a very confrontational manner um even
if you do think things should be slimmed
down which i think lots of people do
agree with and then of course in the
northern ireland protocol where
the prime minister is at least uh
suggesting uh
to that he could unilaterally override
parts of the protocol which would
potentially lead to a trade war with the
brussels and but i think as ever with
boris johnson no one is quite sure how
far he's really going to go
on these various fights and if it's more
talk than action
if boris johnson can't quite make his
mind up who do you think is sort of
leading towards this more aggressive
posturing is it
a staff in number 10 or is it kind of
cabinet cabinet ministers sort of on
their on their own push doing this
yes so i think there are times when
clearly borrowed restaurants is very
behind this agenda it just also has
other voices in his ears saying oh is
this the best way to go about it and but
i think in terms of what you might call
the disruptors in government the ones
who actually do think that the
government should take a combative
approach i think key in number 10 is
david canzini the new deputy chief of
staff and he recently told special
advisers and to go and find wedge issues
in their departments i'm citing the
rwanda policy as an ideal wedge issue
one that divides the opposition and
helps the tories and actually sees i
think there are many ministers who see
the virtue in a way of um including
boris johnson in the courts trying to
disrupt that plan to say you know
they're trying to wrought things we're
on your side and so i think dave and
canceling in number 10 is definitely
behind a more combative tone then i
think you've got jacob reese mogg who um
is seen as the person who is you know
the most out there when it comes to
civil service reform and i think with
jacob rees-mogg there are actually quite
a few cabinet messages do you think that
you can make savings in efficiency but
they're a bit uncomfortable with the
tone by which um jacob rees-mogg is
going about it when it comes to these
letters or you know photo stunts of what
a desk should look like if um suggesting
that his desk we shouldn't have a laptop
on was the was the best or the model of
efficiency and and then of course i
think you have someone like liz trust
who i don't think he's seen is in the
same camp of jacob rees-mogg but
certainly with the protocol i think has
been adopting a rhetoric that is
stronger is in line with david canzini
for example but there are some in number
10 who is saying actually are we
marching ourselves up a hill it's going
to be really hard to get back on and do
we need to tone tone things down so i
think those are some of the ones who are
kind of going out and adopting this more
combative approach
and looking specifically at jacob reese
mog's sort of efforts to slim down the
civil service i mean what's the thinking
here is is he looking to find
efficiencies or do you think he sees it
as a bit of a wedge issue that in the in
the style of david canzini
yes so i think what's interesting on the
civil service reform there are a few
aspects to it and i think generally on
the efficiency point there is broad
support that actually
cutting civil service numbers is
something which uh is a wise thing to do
and i think there's lots of agreement
that in number 10 too at a time when
there's a cost of living crisis the size
of government is too big and i think
that fits with conservative principles
so steve barclay is doing an audit of
the civil service at the moment and some
of those who've been involved in that
were quite um i think surprised to learn
that they're estimated around 700
civil servants working in the cabinet
office just on hr then cop 26 which
we had the presidency all year but
effectively the main summit has come and
gone still has you know over 70 we think
civil servants working on it so figures
like that i think have have this sense
of actually we ca we can cut here but i
think where it strays into a point where
actually now some cabinet ministers
worry that the tone or the style is
going a bit too far
is um in jacob reese mog's approach so
jacob rees-mogg at a recent cabinet told
ministers that the recruitment freeze
they plan to do to cut around 90 000 um
civil service jobs over a course of a
few years um would begin with this
freeze which would also stretch to the
civil service fast stream now i'm told
that some of the ministers in the room
look so appalled by that uh that the
prime minister ultimately intervened and
said i can see you know i can see uh
some of you squirming but we need to
send a strong message um though since
then i think there's some negotiations
going beyond the uh scenes trying to
soften it so it's up to departments who
cuts this and then i think more widely
actually when we're talking about wedge
issues well who
who really are the tory party trying to
divide at the moment because in a way if
you look at the local elections um
the tories lost more seats to liberal
democrats than they did to labor and i
think that uh recently i mean i think
even david kanzini has a technologist at
a recent special advisor meeting saying
we need to also you know what do you
think about the opposition think about
the liberal democrats so what would be a
good wedge issue for the lib dems now
i've spoken to party figures ministers
who are a bit worried that actually this
woman working from home could backfire
some of these voters uh voters in the
south um who might you know switch
between the lib dems and the tories
professional service jobs you've
actually quite embraced um this this way
of more flexi working and therefore what
might get you headlines in some of the
papers or front pages could actually
turn off some of the people you're
trying to bring back in and so i think
that's where you can start to see that
perhaps the tougher rhetoric works one
part the tory coalition but it could
have the opposite effect on another
turning to sort of the other issue of
the day there's sort of been reports
this week of a split between number 10
and the treasury over a windfall energy
tax can you tell us a little bit about
that and what's what's going on there is
this part of the electoral strategy
again or is a bit more of a breakdown
between the treasury and number 10
yeah i mean i don't think anyone thinks
a windfall tax is a wedge issue and i
think but i think there is a there's a
genuine disagreement in government right
now about whether to do this now it used
to be the case that pretty much everyone
in government thought all windfall tax
was a bad idea they thought it set a bad
precedent it could turn away future
investment um but i think in recent
weeks the chancellor and figures in the
treasury started to come around to that
way of thinking along with quite a few
tory mps um just because because i think
a uh the cost of living crisis getting
so bad lots of tory mps want to just
look as though they're doing something
and then secondly um i think from the
treasury perspective having these record
profits from these companies come out
and then the bosses give interviews
saying oh we'll invest in the uk
regardless
of a windfall tax is making and i think
well why not you know it's given this
policy is very popular should we just do
it bring in some money it's not going to
massively change things but um
in a way it is more justified than was a
few months ago now we're going back to
david canzini he's clearly developing
quite a reputation in number 10 at the
moment i think he is one of a group who
takes a view that it is an
unconservative thing to do and this fits
him with the new number 10 approach of
trying to be a more conservative
government and i think it goes against
conservative principles so i think
you've got a situation where probably
the chancellor and his team would go for
this um but those around boris johnson
are trying to push against the idea and
as for boris johnson which i think
probably goes back to our discussion
earlier no one is quite sure where boris
johnson is on this we're told he hasn't
made up his mind um so receiver it goes
but i think generally speaking in a cost
of living crisis it's almost the tories
should just decide whether they're going
to do it or not because every day is i'm
considering doing it and labour pushing
really hard and saying you know why
haven't you done this yet and you begin
to think politically this could be a bit
of a lose-lose whatever happens yeah i
mean do you get the sense in government
that there's some frustration that
they're focusing on these different
wedge issues that you've mentioned at
the time of a cost of living crisis i
mean inflation's at near 10 bills are
going up and we're talking about you
know brexit randa plan i mean is there
some frustration there
i think there's a frustration amongst
tory mps they don't feel there is an
overwhelming narrative when it comes to
an economic plan i had one former
minister say to me recently that at
least with david cameron and osborne you
heard about you know a long-term
economic plan they made the point that
often that plan didn't amount very much
but it definitely meant that you had
something that you could talk about and
point to and i think that
there are lots of touring because who
quite actually like these wedge issues
they think they are things that you know
in a for their form of red meat for some
of their voters and obviously others
feel like they do the opposite but i
think the the bigger issue is the fact
that we're seeing you know inflation uh
rise further really kind of outpacing
many of the forecasts a year or so ago
and there is the sense that government
ministers don't know what to say on the
airwaves when it comes to their plan and
having this arming and airing over a
windfall tax uh pressure for an
emergency budget i think there is just a
bit of a desperation now about tory mps
that they're not sure what they should
be saying the government is doing partly
because it doesn't feel so the
government is sure what it's going to do
and you mentioned there are some other
battles coming up down the road for the
tory party as well can you tell us a
little bit about that
yes i think other uh
potential battles and also if we're
gonna call them wedge issues i mean we
had the channel four privatisation plan
that was in the queen's speech but
nadine doris also told the spectator
recently when i interviewed her that she
planned to set out a new funding formula
for the bbc well before the next
election now the tories would need to
win another term a fifth term uh which
would be historic for a political party
in order to activate these plans but i
think this is going to be looking at you
know moving away from the current
license free model and that again i
think is going to expose these divisions
between
some of these mps in red wall seats who
think that would work well for them and
then some who are you know facing uh
seats where lib dems are the second
largest party and i think it could turn
off some of their voters and then i
think over the summer the big concern at
the moment is actually are we going to
have a summer of rail chaos
with lots of the unions planning large
strikes over pay and at the moment the
plan and government is to face them down
but as you get closer and as
you know the public start to suffer is
that resolve going to weaken
and finally katie um there's been news
this week that a tory mp has been
arrested on allegations of rape um can
you give us any updates about that
situation
yes did this happen earlier this week as
you said we're limited in what we can
say on this but um a tory mp has
arrested been arrested on suspicion of
rape and sexual assault um these are um
alleged defenses relating to some time
ago um at the moment that tory mp has
been told not to
go to the commons not to attend
parliament but they are yet to be
suspended from the tory party and
therefore you're seeing labor and others
saying surely surely you need to do that
but as of yet the government has not
moved
thank you very much katie
one fight the government wants to pick
is over northern ireland downing street
wants britain to unilaterally override
parts of the protocol and the eu is
threatening to put trade sanctions in
place if they do
where is this going to end i'm joined
now by ivan rogers formerly the uk's
ambassador to the eu
brilliant thank you ivan for joining us
on spectator tv
now this week liz trust announced
changes to the northern ireland protocol
she's going to bring in sort of a take
back control bill to potentially
unilaterally change the protocol um ivan
what did you make of her statement this
week and of what she said
well first of all thanks very much for
inviting me um
well clearly um we're entering another
new phase of of this very protracted
saga um it didn't uh enormously surprise
me what she said um nor has the reaction
uh i think around the european union
surprised me i think we'll see obviously
when precisely the legislation gets
introduced if it gets introduced at all
my expectation is that they will go
ahead and introduce something before the
summer and will be obliged to do but
obviously in in the best of all worlds
there would still be a resolution a
negotiated resolution of this before we
get to the stage
of legislation
that doesn't in all canada seem to me to
be terribly likely from everything i
hear from uh from other sources
if we get to the point where the uk
government proceeds and uh at least in
the view of the european union is
proceeding uh contrary to international
law because they won't accept the uk
government's view that this is in line
with international law or doesn't breach
it
then i think life does become
more complex again it's already complex
enough uh there hasn't been enough
progress in the negotiations i
understand you know where the uk
government thinks it's going with this
but it will get a counter reaction where
i think the the eu will
institute or reinstitute legal
proceedings
and will freeze the so-called positive
agenda with the uk
and will probably declare um
uh a subsequent series of potential
retaliatory steps in the event in the
event that the legislation proceeds so
we're at you know as we know in northern
ireland um
anyway whereas a very difficult juncture
uh the politics of this are extremely uh
tricky in northern ireland um in london
and in the eu
and
we may by the autumn be in even stormier
waters
i mean ivan the uk must know that
they're sort of heading towards a clash
with the eu what do you think the uk
government's sort of long-term plan is
is this is all about domestic signaling
or do you think they can actually get
any sort of concessions
well now the question is do they want um
what i would call sort of pragmatic and
technical uh concessions um uh
improvements easements in the way in
which the existing protocol
uh operates
or do they want a fundamental change the
protocol if you listen to what she said
and she talks about the need to uh
change the
commissioner's mandate commissioner
chefkovich's mandate and get the council
of ministers to change his mandate
they're talking about a much more
fundamental rewrite of the protocol
if that's the agenda um
in all canada i don't think the european
union is going to change his mandate i
don't think there's any appetite for
member states to reopen the text
and i think we're heading for a major
crunch and probably a breakdown
i don't personally think that you need
to change the commissioner's mandate in
order to make quite serious progress on
some of the technical issues that she's
raised some of the seven points that liz
trust made
laid out the other day i don't think you
need to revise the mandate of the
commissioner in order to make progress
on at least some of those but i suppose
let's step back a bit what what is the
what is the protocol solution
we all know the origins of it and what
happened in the three years running up
to 2019
the solution that we adopted or that was
adopted
was essentially to fit with boris
johnson's version of brexit rather than
theresa may's version of brexit but what
it entailed was leaving northern ireland
in the european union single market for
goods
uh you know you can like that or you can
loathe it you can think it's the right
solution or the wrong solution i've said
for several years now there is no single
optimal solution that works perfectly
for everybody this was always going to
be pretty messy that's the solution
uh that was adopted what does that mean
well it entails some of the consequences
that you're now seeing in terms of uh
trade flows in terms of dislocations of
trade
it also means it's quite a you know in
in the first instance it's quite a
surprising and generous offer from the
european union because after all it's
giving the northern northern irish
economy privileged status where it has
much better access to the european
single market than the rest of great
britain
but is still part of the british single
market as well albeit imperfectly
the second thing it does and this causes
the difficulty with the british side and
i can understand both arguments here
what has the eu agreed to do it's
contracted out essentially
the policing of one chunk of its
external border its external trade
border to a third country namely us
now that's not nothing actually i mean i
understand why um it's causing a huge
amount of grief for the uk authorities
and
for some at least in northern ireland
and why it's a problem the operation of
it is a problem but it's not nothing to
say we trust a third country the british
who've left the club
to operate are a chunk of our external
border
but the difficult the difficulty with
that um just just to just to finish on
that point is pretty obvious you then
have to trust the british to do that
properly and then the definition of what
doing it properly means of course is
very different in brussels
from how it looks in london and there
there the devil as we're seeing lies in
the detail of
is the eu demanding
that the uk authorities
operate the external border and police
the external border in a way which given
it's not an external border in a in the
sense of other other borders it's an
internal trade border within two
different parts of the united kingdom is
it insisting on things that are so
onerous that they cause a huge problem
not only for the business community but
for political sentiment particularly on
the unionist side in northern ireland
that's the crux of it i think
i mean if we go down that path and sort
of heading head towards a clash with you
i mean you mentioned earlier on about
retaliatory measures that you could take
what would they look like do you think
well i think in the first instance if
the uk government proceeds to table the
legislation which the foreign secretary
referred to the the eu is banned i think
to institute legal proceedings or
reinstitute legal proceedings and put
that back on the table saying this is
already a breach of the northern ireland
protocol and we're proceeding with legal
action that's the first thing they do
i think the second thing they would do
is freeze the so-called positive agenda
so the other agenda items with the
british where where there were potential
win-wins those can be science or
education or research or you know
multiple things that are going on in the
undergrowth some with political interest
others not
in a whole range of sectors i think they
would say unless until the uk takes its
legislation off the table again all of
this stuff is going in the freezer
and then the third thing you do i think
and i would expect to see is they would
say if this bill proceeds through its
stages and is effectively being whipped
through the commons
so that tory mps are obliged to vote for
it because the government intends to put
it on the statute book
then we will uh take specific
retaliatory measures i would expect
those not to be
a threat of full suspension of the
entire trade and cooperation agreement
that we may get there over the course of
the next year or two and putting the
whole thing because they will say this
is a package the northern ireland
protocol and the tca will and in the end
if you blow up the northern ireland
protocol then the tca won't survive
i don't think they move there first off
i think this would be quite a slow
calibrated ratchet process where they
will say if you proceed through all
stages of this bill there will be
specific retaliatory action that's most
likely to target specific industries you
know specific ministers constituencies
frankly just try and target some things
which concentrate some minds in london
as to the wisdom of going down the
unilateralist course does it do i think
that works i i mean
why am i a little bit um cautious about
the prospects of avoiding a trade deal i
think if you get to that point where the
uk introduces legislation and the eu
retaliates first of all by taking legal
action
secondly by freezing the positive agenda
thirdly by threatening further sort of
calibrated steps of retaliation
um if you're in that game do we really
think that the mood in the early autumn
would be propitious enough for liz truss
and marish sefkovic to make real
progress in technical negotiations it
seems to me the mood then is so sour you
know will have been through the marching
season in northern ireland will have
been through the conference season here
there will be equal preoccupations on
the other side of the table about are
the british serious
um i think then the prospect that the
mood would be
jolly enough between the two sides to
make serious determined progress on
technical issues it's quite it's quite
hard to imagine isn't it so i think if
we get to that if we get to that point
the other side of the summer where we're
starting to go down a unilateralist
route in this country then i think
there's quite a high risk that you lurch
gradually into a trade war
i mean ivan do you think there's the
sort of unity on the eu side to do that
though because i imagine there'll be
plenty of countries thinking for example
that you know there's a natural war
going on on european soil on the other
end of the continent is this the time to
be starting a trade war with britain i
mean what do you think if is the eu
resolve there to do that to go down
those measures
well it's great question i mean i saw um
you know another wonderful tweet from uh
my old friend and uh boss david davis
the other day which said you know you've
got to take it out of the hands of these
ghastly uh theologians and eurocrats in
brussels and boris johnson must conduct
a tour of leaders around europe
i have to say i've been there so many
times in in my career what what tends to
happen of course is that leaders are of
course grateful as indeed they should be
for uk efforts on
um their external security and the
external security of the eastern border
and that applies to the baltic states
and the polls and other eastern
europeans
and that's a good thing and overall that
should be improving um
uh uk eu relations at a time when
after all we're facing the worst
violence and the worst aggression on
european soil since the second world war
it doesn't count for nothing the problem
is and as i say i have seen this any
number of times before does that
translate into either leaders or their
apparatus in brussels taking a position
which distances themselves from the
european commission or from the council
secretariat who run the process in
brussels in my experience no it never
does so would i expect that to translate
into the baltic states or the poles or
the hungarians or whoever standing up in
brussels and saying we mustn't go down
this route and we mustn't end up in a
trade war with the british now i don't
think that will happen i'm afraid and i
think this is a constant
misunderstanding inside the british
system i've lived through for you know
decades of believing
there has to be a translation across
from you know why wider ga strategic
uh cooperation on the defense and
security side into the way in which
dossier is like the northern ireland
protocol
um
uh you know work i
i'm not saying that's a good thing or a
bad thing i'm just saying all my
experience of the way in which the eu
actually operates on this
is that when it comes to the european
council when it comes to leaders circles
when it comes to permanent
representatives the ambassadors sitting
in brussels this stuff won't actually
play like that and there will be full
solidarity to go down the path that the
commission and the council secretariat
prescribe so i think if the brits are
calculating that that won't be the case
this time because of the ukraine russia
war i think they're making another
miscalculation
brilliant thank you very much ivan
and finally is the bbc trying to hide a
radical series it made in the 1960s for
fear of a backlash against the
programme's position on drugs sexuality
and abortion
peter hitchens writes in this week's
magazine that adaption of jean-paul
sartre's the roads to freedom been kept
from public view for over 50 years but
he's managed to view a bootleg copy
peter joins the week in 60 minutes now
thank you peter for joining us now peter
you're one of the few people who've seen
roadster freedom since it last aired on
television for viewers who aren't
familiar with it at all can you explain
a bit about the show what it's about and
kind of why it's so important
well it's a marvelous crisp concise
dramatization of jean-paul satra's
enormous trilogy the rose to freedom
which
which
covered the the last months of peace uh
set in left-back paris and is full of
all kinds of extraordinary events and
philosophical discussions about human
freedom you wouldn't have thought it was
it was filmable but it was brilliantly
filmed one of the first things the bbc
ever filmed in color in that rather nice
artistic greenish color they used to do
things in back in the 60s and it aired
in 1970 just at the very end of the 60s
as they were slipping forever
away from us and
i i am a huge number of other people
watched it completely enthralled
and it left a great impression on my
mind not least the the the actual the
theme music the song which was sung at
the opening and the closing of each
of each episode
wrote the uh la ritted europe by sung by
georgie brown
and
many years later
thinking
that it might be interesting to see it
again when a lot of old tv programs are
re-emerging
i i've made some inquiries and found
this extraordinary story about it it
does exist
but it can't be shown it was shown once
to an audience of the british film
institute
about 10 years ago
over a weekend but it's it can't
apparently be shown on television the
bbc terribly evasive if you ask them why
not and they say they have no plans to
show it but we know it exists and there
it is so i i
having written a bit about this mystery
in my mail on sunday column i was
invited through a series of secret
meetings and past words and speak easy
arrangements to actually see it and so
eventually did
and it is as i thought it would be the
most extraordinary evocation of the last
years of the 1960s and also a very
satisfying piece of drama it's a great
shame it can't be shown but i i think i
can see why i mean some of our viewers
might be asking fairly you know the bbc
has thousands of shows in its archive
you know it can't show all of them is it
is it just a procedural cost kind of
thing why it can't be shown do you think
or do you think there's something more
going on there
well i think there's something more
going on i can't prove it but i think
it's very interesting things a huge
difference between what the radical left
was like in 1970 and what it's like now
and there's a particular character
daniel played by the fantastic actor
daniel massey uh who is a homosexual
character and he's portrayed very much
as he is in in satra's
book
as a a as a as a man who strongly
dislikes himself and a lot of what he
does
uh and also has a rather
ambivalent feelings when the nazis
eventually arrive in paris which are not
really greatly to his credit
and i think that the bbc
probably fear that if they showed this
that a lot of people would think that it
was
it was saying something that it wasn't
saying look we all nobody speaks about
these things as they spoke about them in
1970 anyway
but there was something about that
character who's immensely important in
in the whole series which i think they
they think would bring them trouble from
from from modern radicals and so a very
radical program now can't be shown i
think because of the fear of what modern
radicals would make of it great pity it
is a great watch yeah i mean you
mentioned in your piece there's a lot of
attitudes have changed around sort of
sexism and abortion and and various
other things like that do you think
that's why it makes such it might make
such uncomfortable viewing for sort of
the bbc it's mainly the character the
homosexual character daniel it it is it
is mainly him as i say he's he's he's
very important in the book and
he made even more important daniel
massey steals the show in some ways
on many occasions sort of acts uh the
the the
the titular star michael bryant off the
screen
and you couldn't cut it out now but if
you left it in i can just see the sort
of people who like making trouble about
that sort of thing making trouble
people have to understand that the left
back in 1970 the 1960s left was was but
mainly uh still very much more a
communist and the marxist sort of left
the kind that sartre understood it
didn't have the same sexually
revolutionary positions that it has now
female comrades were still expected to
make the tea and savages for the
demonstrations and so forth and
everything that went with that for
instance and attitudes towards
homosexuals and other minorities were
still i think pretty it's suffused with
the with the prejudices of the sort of
sort of society it was then and that
wouldn't translate well into the
into this decade do you still think the
show has sort of value today though for
us then if it is sort of very very
different types i think so i think i say
the the the books i i greatly
appreciated the books i hear this is
this is an actual souvenir from the
1960s this is i see from the fly leaf
that i gave it to myself on my birthday
in 1968 five shillings which some idiot
will translate as 25 p it's a wholly
different currency in a whole different
world and the 1960s are
an era which people find it increasingly
difficult to imagine if they weren't in
them even i who was in them have
difficulty in believing a lot of what
took place part of the reason i wanted
to watch the series was was to see how
how my memory actually fitted with with
reality and it is is say
extraordinarily evocative not least
because it contains so much brilliant
acting talent and of course it's like so
many things in the 60s it's a wonderful
film of romeo and juliet which has the
same atmosphere you feel very strongly
that this is at the end of the
at the end of the old culture when
people were still making things who
understood about shakespeare and the
classics in a way they no longer do it
has a very strong quality of having been
made by highly educated people
of a kind who've almost entirely
disappeared from among us it's very
nostalgic and and rather moving from
that point of view and i wish that other
people could see it but i can't i can't
arrange for that to happen
you mentioned your piece it sort of
breaks with the puritanical morality of
the day do you think it could have the
same impact today or do you think it's
more of an interest to sort of as a as
an insight into the decade of the 60s
more in that way
well no it's a reverse impact because
it's quite obvious that the the the
sergeant character matteo de la rue is
is quite is quite squeamish about the
possibility of obtaining the abortion he
spends most of the first few episodes
trying to get for his mistress he
recognizes that it's an act of
destruction well these days of course
abortion on the left is a sort of
sacrament and a woman's right to choose
and all the rest of it i'm not sure that
would go down very well either uh the
the position of the women in in
in the drama is also
one which i i think a lot of modern
feminists would find would find made
them rather uncomfortable the references
to drugs are pretty pejorative as well
uh the lola montero the the chanteurs
who is a major character and sings laura
tendura is ruining her life with cocaine
quite evidently and there's there's not
much scruple made about that and you
mentioned in the beginning there that
you um
you did manage to see her screenings
these sort of various clandestine
methods and can you tell us a bit about
that or or you can tell us about that
nothing at all no my my lips are whole
is sealed
i can't reveal anything about it at all
you weren't snuck into the bbc
headquarters in about in a diplomatic
bag kind of thing
you can't you can't tempt me i i'm just
not going to tell you
fair enough i'd be wrong
enormous good fortune in
in in seeing it but i i wish i could
share it with other people but i can't
and do you have any hope that it will be
maybe if you make enough noise about it
someone will approach you on a street
caller one evening and say
i have here a copy of the rest of
freedom you want to watch it but maybe
they won't do i mean do you have any
hope at all that it will ever be
released or is that a bit of a pipe
dream at this stage
i think that the problem is that
although i think that the objections to
showing it are stupid
uh they're they're they're also wise
because the the
you can see why somebody would say i
don't really want to wish i don't really
want to risk
the
the the possible fuss that would be made
about showing this by people who don't
understand it and don't want to
understand it and just want to make it
fast there are i think a lot of people
who will travel a long way in modern
society to be offended by something
and this would give those people such an
opportunity and you can see why people
sitting down in the community if they've
got the freedom to say and they have the
freedom of course
to say that they won't screen it then
the chances are they'll take the easy
option and and leave it in the archive
it leads mr next question which is you
know do you think anything like it could
be made today
not a chance
i the the the people don't exist the the
sort of talent as i say the the the
level of education and understanding of
classical training uh that went into it
uh the and also the the audience that it
was aimed at who were also considered to
be uh educated and informed in a way
that audiences aren't these days don't
exist it's it's a relic of another era
that's another reason why it's so moving
to watch it brilliant thank you very
much peter and uh before you go we've
spent the day at the spectator trying to
track down even just a clip of this
television show we even contacted the
director's family but to no avail but we
have managed to get hold of which is
available online the show's title track
and music which was composed by the
director himself so we're just going to
play that now for you
[Music]
good
[Music]
see
that's it for this week once again we're
delighted that canaccord genuity wealth
management is sponsoring the week in 60
minutes can accord will provide the
expertise you need to build your wealth
with confidence you can visit can do
wealth dot com to find out more
and don't forget to subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel as well just
click the subscribe button button at the
bottom of this video and tap the bell
icon so you never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
you